he's our biggest threat he's obviously
gonna win the presidency if he's not
slandered and stopped and he's the
biggest threat to the medical
pharmaceutical do you think he has a
chance of winning the presidency well
Michelle Obama apparently is going to
run so no what about Gavin Newsom he
seems to be he'll probably be Michelle's
VP probably I think so I think if
Michelle runs Newsome won't stand a
chance Michelle Obama have any more
qualifications than Hillary Clinton did
I think she has less I think she
actually has less she lives Secretary of
State yeah yeah I think she says I think
part of the fear qualification right is
being first lady completely personable
from knowing Obama compared to Hillary
isn't she isn't she like anti-fat people
though remember her whole oh get out and
move yeah
I think that's all right I think it's
interesting because you're right there
are lots of cool nice things people in
the world that doesn't mean they all
should be president but with RFK I think
the biggest threat is not necessarily
that he would win as a Democrat it's
that he would run as a third party and
siphon votes away